titan personne ne tente l'impossible
sans croire en quelque chose de plus
gros que lui même
nos ressources sont complètement épuisé
dans dix ans la planète sera inhabitable
mais il y à un endroit qui nous permet
d'espérer et city temps pouvait devenir
notre monde
je vais vous faire plus de 300
injections dans les prochaines semaines
injection de quoi vous allez devenir des
humains améliorée des superman beaucoup
vont échouer
certains vont craquer pendant
l'entraînement calme at war
imaginez pas que je verrai ça un jour
heureux que notre avenir
tu seras le premier rhum sur titan
[Musique]
serait plus respirer il est en train de
changer
ça ce n'est pas de la recherche spatiale
c'est criminel
je veux finir le programme je vois mieux
que jamais il ya aucune obscurité
quelque chose de vivant lee c'est un
soldat fait 300 millions de dollars de
recherche scientifique il est impossible
de reculer
si on ne peut pas le contrôler on va
tous mourir
titan le 30 mars henri cinéma / au
service de vidéo à la demande
exclusivement chez vous